let's do some media news over the fourth
of july weekend there was such major
media news it has shaken the media world
to its very core
jordan peterson who has previously said
he's not political and he's certainly
not right wing is joining the new
right-wing online network the daily wire
the daily wire is apparently now
launching their
i would it's weird it's not even really
like it's all streaming it's all online
anyway they're launching something
called daily wire plus and i don't know
if plus means it's better or it's sort
of like the dregs that nobody wants but
anyway it's daily wire plus jordan
peterson is going to have a program on
the daily wire plus the the uh trailer
for this program
looks like it would be a parody
of what you would expect to see from
someone like jordan peterson i watched
this thing twice and i rarely am even
remotely entertained by this stuff
but
this is just wacky the program is called
dragons monsters and men now for those
of you thinking maybe i can find it on
youtube or maybe i can find it on roku
or tick tocks or fire sticks or anything
it will only be on daily wire plus i
don't want you guys to get your hopes up
and think you're just going to be able
to go anywhere and find jordan
peterson's dragons monsters and men
here is
i mean a parody of himself at this point
jordan peterson's new program one of the
things i tell young men well in young
women as well but the young men really
need to hear this more i think you
should be a monster an absolute monster
and then you should learn how to control
it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than
one who cannot do that and so you're
willing to go get a job but you're
terrified of an interview it's like
there's a dragon for you because you
want to fight the dragons that guard the
gates of the treasure that you wish to
attain i hope you guys are particularly
the men the women too like he says but
particularly the men i hope you guys are
taking notes um why at this point i mean
listen uh you can be
you can be a good therapist but have
personally a life
that is not going so well
interpersonally you could be a good
nutritionist but personally
like crap but like
i think you guys get the analogy but at
this point
peterson's entire life is a shambles
that seems so
uh um
sort of like
uh
unhinged and outrageous
in every way
that i don't know why people would still
be saying this is the picture of
stability
and the p i just don't get it i really
don't get it at this point it doesn't
make any sense to me
the productivity
requires aim orientation responsibility
discipline that willingness to work that
willingness to make sacrifices which is
the hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher goal even the way they have
them sitting in the chair if you're
watching every down to the last note
every element of this is bizarre
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
right
why do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're going to have to lead you're
going to have to convince you're going
to have to think to say to a 18 year old
you're okay the way you are
that just deflates them
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of
news it's almost like the the i think
what at this point has become kind of
weird about all of this is
it's gone beyond eve it it's now just
approximating in the blurriest sense
possible
what is actually actionable advice like
early on there was the first layer of
the jordan peterson stuff where it was
like okay he's sort of giving specific
advice like self-help type stuff
and it's completely
uh unremarkable in that it's a lot of
the same stuff that a lot of people have
been repeating for a long time and so to
the extent that it's useful to hear it
from anybody it might be useful
he now just even dances around it in
such generalities that it's almost like
a horoscope it's the horoscope version
there's been these tests done with
horoscopes where you get people of
different astrological signs i don't
know are there 10 or 12 of them and you
give them all the same horoscope and
they all start to believe if you tell
them that it's the horoscope for their
sign that it applies to them perfectly
even though it's just random it has not
no meaning whatsoever it's sort of a
similar thing where it's just like it's
the most generic possible advice and
it's so generic that people just hear
and they go yeah that sounds reasonable
but there's not actually anything to
really act on it's a very it's almost
become a grift of sorts at this point
things that you had no idea you were
capable of will make themselves manifest
those are the dragons you know the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the
light
and you have to say to yourself
i will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision because maybe you're
great
the only thing missing would be jordan
peterson uh weeping now to announce this
incredible partnership
ben shapiro interviewed i guess jordan
peterson and ben shapiro asked one
question
and then uh peterson just droned on and
on and on i've never seen anything like
that i've had interview guests where
it's like close to this but it's never
been this bad
[Applause]
at you for even talking to men
well i think it's i think you could
think about it as a consequence in some
sense of the lack of a concept of
original sin
right now i just dipped into it at
random like i just clicked around and
peterson's just droning at every
instance compassion that has this
devouring quality and
yeah and that's basically where we're at
so
so
i found the other question shapiro was
able to ask
you know it's
one of the things that's striking about
the sort of hatred that you've gotten
from so many is that you you've
literally been asked why you're even
bothering to speak to men i mean there
is this crisis masculinity right there
is this idea that so he basically asks
the same question again and then
peterson's just going and go power
i'll define that as the willingness and
ability to use compulsion
to attain your aims now if you are
someone who has a proclivity to manifest
power right okay here's another one
power is the fundamental
motivation and that's and then you think
too
okay you're only motivated by power that
means that we can only get along if our
interests align because if you're
motivated okay and then just one other
moment this is the manifestation of the
spirit of voluntary play and that's so
lovely because there's nothing all right
i'm not gonna subject you guys to more
of it but that is the new partnership
jordan peterson who's not political and
not a right winger partnering up with
the hard right media conglomerate the
daily wire i'm sure it will be a
fascinating show if any of you watch it
please let me know
how
did you survive